Speaker 1: This is a very interesting legal
story in terms of the precedent that it could
set.
And we knew it was only a matter of time until
this was happening.
And it's happening now.
The lawyer of one of the Trump writers who
has been charged for his role in the January
6th riots, which were, of course, inspired
by Donald Trump, is using so-called Fox mania.
And Fox IDUs as a defense for his client,
the 27 year old is charged, Anthony Antonio
is his name, 27 year old Anthony Antonio is
charged with unlawful and violent entry of
the Capitol Police, obstruction and destruction
of government property, according to an arrest
warrant.
The lawyer for Anthony Antonio, whose name
is Joseph Hurley, claims that Fox News is
to blame for the alleged actions of his client.
His attorney said, as reported by Huff Post,
quote, Fox itis.
He became hooked with what I call Fox mania.
Antônio, quote, started believing what was
being fed to him, says his lawyer.
And there is a very dangerous and never ending
circle of liability here to consider, because
here you have a lawyer blaming Fox News.
And Fox News in the past has used it as a
legal defense that at least their opinion
programing is merely entertainment.
It's not news.
None of it should be taken literally.
And so is anyone to blame for this guy's actions?
I know that as the party of personal responsibility,
you would think the right would be saying,
well, the individual is to blame, but is anyone
actually going to be held accountable?
And certainly, I mean, listen, what the lawyer
is saying isn't crazy.
There's much reason to think that Fox News
and Newsmax and O.J. and they are partially
to blame for inciting and ginning these people
up for months with claims of election fraud.
But there is also plenty of reason to think
that Antônio himself has to be responsible
here.
We have in the exhibits in this particular
case, video footage that shows the defendant
wearing a bulletproof vest with a patch representing
the three percenters, which is an extremist
anti-government group.
He is seen shouting at officers in the crowd
on video saying, you want war.
We got war 1776 all over again.
Antônio was later captured on video being
handed a riot shield which seemed to have
been stolen law enforcement property.
He eventually used that shield to push his
way to the front of the crowd.
And then he was seen squirting water on a
police officer who was then dragged into the
crowd throwing a bottle in the direction of
police officers.
It can't all be Fox News's fault, right?
Although I do agree that the role of media
in getting people fired up by airing endless
conspiracies, even if, as they say, our guests
were saying those things, we weren't saying
those things, there's no doubt that that's
an aspect of this.
But Fox made me do it.
That's it.
Who didn't see this defense coming, though?
We it was obviously going to be fingers pointing
at other people even.
Oh, he just got caught up in the group.
He got kind of pushed in by the mob into the
into the Capitol building.
Now, of course, they could also argue in court.
That actually it was Trump, as much as Fox
News is to blame, Trump is to blame.
Call it, you know, instead of FOX, itis Trump
area or something like that.
But that seems less likely to play as well
as maybe this could.
And I don't know if this will work.
We're going to have to follow the case.
Is there a treatment for Trump Arria?
Is there an antidote to Fox itis or Fox mania?
So we're going to follow the case.
We'll see what impact it has on the court,
because the precedent setting power of this
could be significant.
And I would be if this works at all, I expect
to see many of the defense lawyers for those
charged in the January six Trump riots to
try to use exactly this defense.
Let me know if you think it will work, but
also, you know, not maybe not from a legal
standpoint, but obviously the rioters deserve
the lion's share of the consequences for what
they did.
But how do you think blame should go around
between merely the rioters themselves who
did the thing?
Donald Trump and right wing media that ginned
this stuff up for months, how would you split
it up 60, 20, 20, 80, 10, 10?
I don't know.
Let me know what you think and we'll have
a follow up about it.